and magnus he has the white pieces in
this one he has been under pressure from
the chinese so far today but in this
game very slightly over to the world
champions side yeah early days and
actually just uh an hour or two ago
ivanka you mentioned the catalan opening
that's been a battleground between these
two throughout their entire careers at
any time they face each other usually
it's actually ding on the white side of
the catalan opening but this time it's
magnus with white using an opening that
actually brought him success in the
world championship match against
napoleonicity and uh it's early days
material is level if we do a quick count
and it's relatively balanced pawn
structure as well relatively symmetrical
so it's uh yeah anyone's game the
computer prefers white slightly maybe
because his pieces are more centralized
uh black having a
light-squared bishop that's kind of
staring against its own pawns white's
queen slightly more active than black's
queen but uh in general these positions
tend to be known as relatively balanced
and i think ding won't be too unhappy
with the outcome of the opening despite
the fact he's used a bit more time on
the clock magnus not looking too excited
either
it's uh very much balanced right now and
norman from germany donated 35
uh 34 sorry to our fundraiser for unicef
another
jurg from germany as well it's so nice
to see that we have viewers all over the
world i saw nepal earlier i've seen
italy and it's also so nice to see that
you are
donating to unicef doing their
life-saving work for the people caught
up in war inside ukraine and now
becoming refugees children their mothers
fleeing from the war all money in our
unicef
fundraiser
will be going to those people who
desperately need it so thank you and
please keep on donating our goal is now
120 000 and you can use this qr code and
uh that will um guide you straight to to
the donation site yeah it would be nice
to get like a hundred thousand dollars
yes by the end of today
lovely round number and that would be
such a fantastic effort from all of us
the chess community just clubbing
together to help unicef and just help
the children help all the refugees and
those displaced
um yeah well
my heart and everyone's hearts go out to
the ukrainian people absolutely yeah it
was uh very um moving and hard to to
hear the other day when we had grand
master pavliano from inside ukraine
talking to us on skype
just telling some heartbreaking stories
about what he's seeing inside ukraine
and also his chess colleagues
fighting in the war
it is heartbreaking stories and
the only thing we can do is help by
donating money for organizations like
unicef to do their life saving work yeah
imagine how many children we could help
if we do hit that target yeah that would
be that is so true yeah yeah and uh 30
minutes left 31 minutes left in the
auction for
that uh success secret lab gaming chair
current bid one thousand three hundred
and fifty dollars wow it's a very
special gaming chair it is it brings its
uh occupiers luck as we saw with david
and uh it's actually an incredible chair
we've sat on it so comfortable very
comfortable perfect to sit in and of
course it comes with pedigrees yeah
often that you get a game gaming chair
that magnus carlsen young christophe
duda and anish geary david howell
caias nara
[Laughter]
satin and new vancouver yeah i didn't
want to mention myself
i decided as well um yeah
and whilst we're waiting for magnus to
think of a move and think of a plan um i
wanted to share with you a few selfies
we have cherry puffling
who says that their favorite two ways to
relax and uh magnus stepping forward
with the queen eyeing up the pawn
on b5 and quickly initiating
a knight maneuver maneuver
magnus just clearing also the c file so
there's a couple of rooks looking at
each other on the only open file on the
board we could see a rook trade i think
white's knight is maybe going to do a
bit of a dance to try and
get into the black half but it needs to
take three or four moves so magnus just
spent five minutes on this clock trying
to come up with a long-term plan
yeah and i did say that uh david's
reaction would be made into a meme
and uh he is
mr savant don't worry david they've also
made me as well so mr salman x says me
when i check mate my opponent with 0.1
seconds
that is a super cool view that is very
cool yeah
all right
thanks for being so kind
i'm trying to come up with a good meme
myself for using that when when would my
reaction be like that
you're playing golf car when i'm playing
golf yeah
oh that is so cool yeah keep those memes
coming that is very cool and another
move on the board yeah so black's last
move i really like i really like ding's
entry of the black rook into the white
half of the board supported by a couple
of pawns any captures there would have
only helped black and meanwhile magnus
feeling he needs to take time out to
push this pawn that's a bit of a strange
one to me uh yes white's structure is
now solidified if you look on the right
half of the board it's like a v
structure with white's pawns but uh yeah
it does block in white's dart squad
bishop white star squad bishop actually
lacking escape squares if black can
attack it later
it might regret not being able to slide
back so a committal move by magnus and
feels like ding has a move or two maybe
to get the black queen out of the way to
bring the other black rook into the game
and uh yeah i think
ding is going to be delighted with how
the game is turning white is retreating
knights blocking up his position with
pawns
black meanwhile getting active are you
thinking
about making the same move that i'm
thinking
when you said move the queen out of the
way put her in the corner
which looks which looks a little bit
ridiculous you know at first sight
please just after all what is the queen
doing that but uh like david said
gets the queen out of the way so that
the rook sitting next to the king can
actually join in the fun and start
aligning yourself with its sibling there
yeah it's all about this open file the c
file and the reason we want to go to the
corner as well is because suddenly if
you do plant yourself in the corner rook
takes rook will always be met by this
capture and suddenly look at the power
of the queen and bishop on this diagonal
they're just pointing down attacking
knights and uh suddenly black would be
in complete control so this is actually
quite a thematic quite a typical idea
planting the queen in the corner in
anticipation of the position opening up
later you use the queen and bishop on
the same diagonal if the center of the
board opens up and uh okay ding didn't
go for this maybe just uh undecided
where he wants his queen maybe the queen
can come this direction as well so
instead he takes a timeout very sensible
timeout just pushes a pawn uh there's
two purposes behind this move firstly
creating an escape square for the king
later on never ever any background
checkmates anymore but also uh the other
idea i mentioned earlier this bishop
lacking escape squares and you could
hint at maybe a later pawn push you need
to prepare it with three or four moves
but you could hint that you'll push this
one forward later and try to annoy this
bishop so uh okay interesting idea
biting yeah i i really dislike it
actually
i think it's too slow because after
magnus's night retreat which was the
plan i think i'm thinking that black
really can't be going but it might be
forced to rook takes rook because once
white recaptures
there is no contest from black for the
sea lion meanwhile if our queen if the
queen had been on a8
well the black rook could have
challenged yeah that's true actually
maybe it's just timing and ding ding did
actually shake his head there if you
notice uh he may be lacking time now to
challenge these rooks because suddenly
white is the one occupying this line if
the trade happens and maybe the trade
has to happen as yvanga mentions because
of this rook attacked by white's knight
let's go back to the players big
decision for deng does he leave his rook
on the square and sacrifice
or does he just give up control of the
key open c file
at the moment it's just small margins
and
he might have to give up control he's
really not looking happy ding shaking
his head a few moments ago and now
leaning in as ivanka mentions just one
move too slow now for black and it was
just that luxury porn move
um i like the idea behind it it's the
type of move black definitely wants to
play but maybe he just chose the wrong
plan in the wrong order
and uh yeah what to do now that is the
question to trade rooks the other
alternative may be to bring the rook
back to the top of the board but that
doesn't really help it will just end up
in almost the same position uh ding
shaking his head again
look at the clock times he has to move
just trade the rooks move the queen it's
not that bad for black still and one
open file for white looks good but maybe
he can challenge for it later in the
game he needs to move the clock times
not on his side
this is the first time we've seen magnus
establish a big time advantage actually
and uh will that decide this game so
okay the rooks have come off and finally
this uh move we've been advocating we've
been cheering for the black queen does
plant herself in the corner of the board
not just because she's on actually a
decent square there but also clearing
the way for her rook to come and
challenge for the sea life
but it might be a little bit too late
because now the white rook can dive in
okay oh nice nice strategical idea
actually interesting yeah and this idea
it's actually borrowed from a few
different openings and this bishop
actually plugs the c file so if the
black comes across as it does
the white bishop i was going to say
could stay there for a few more moves
just blocking in the black rook it's
actually zig zagging back i mentioned it
didn't have many escape squares he wants
to challenge black's dark square bishop
because if the two dart square bishops
get removed from the board white's light
squad bishop is actually superior to
black to his counterpart yeah a very
instructive strategy here
you know
ivan salgado in his chess 24 premium
course says magnus must have known which
pieces to trade here he is he's giving
us a masterclass in this
if he trades the dark square bishops
magnus is going to be a big favorite to
win this game okay
wow ding meanwhile retreating his knight
not because the knight was bad but he
wants to actually maybe bring it towards
the center towards this left side of the
board and maybe block any potential
bishop trades
so yeah it's a race against the clock
for ding but it's also a race to stop
magnus achieving his ideal trades all
right and remember cctauction.com
to make your bid on the successful
secret lab gaming chair
23 minutes left before that auction ends
current bid 1
350
cctauction.com
for one of the most successful gaming
chairs out there
all right magnus carlson even sat in it
and magnus carlsen
could be about to win a very important
game in the semi-final match yep still a
lot of hard work to be done but the
momentum is slightly in white's favor
okay i'm surprised by this one though
white's queen came back i was going to
say just to support the rook next to it
and just to guard there and uh now
magnus is the one to initiate the rook
exchange i thought maybe he would have
tried to delay this as long as possible
his idea must be actually to bring the
black queen away from the corner square
where it wants to be
if the black queen now captures the
white rook the white light the white
dark square bishop sorry on the side of
the board it's gonna slide back one
square and create an annoying pin so
magnus he's just trying to force the
opponent's pieces to bad squares
it's not so
important now having the open file once
the rooks have all disappeared um so
he's allowing the black queen to come
and capture this rook
will ding go for that will he take back
with the knight he does capture with the
queen yeah the most natural move it is
the most natural move and there you kind
of read magnus's mind you know how he
works bishop drops back and the reason
he wants to lure the black queen away
from the corner square is because the
black pawn on the a fire now cannot go
and challenge this bishop it would have
been able to if black's queen was in the
corner but that pawn would be unguarded
now so magnus he's arranged this
annoying pin with his lights with his
last move this star squad bishop
and still white has the plan in his
pocket of actually maneuvering his
knights and jumping into that outpost uh
that's c5 square
yep it's all about the dark squares if
you notice black light squared pawns on
the left side in the center they don't
cover the dark squares so it is about
that battle for the dark squares white
meanwhile more flexible with his
structure and black's knights jumping
over towards the left but they're not
going to get too far they will be
prevented later on
they will be evicted if they ever jump
into white's half
yeah still it might look to viewers at
home it might look very very symmetrical
no material imbalance no attack incoming
for either side but this is pure
strategy
it's just maneuvering which pieces to
trade which pieces to keep on the board
and magnus is the master at that that's
why maybe we give him such high chances
of winning this game
yep and finally ding does manage to push
this pawn to attack the bishop so the
bishop moves
to a nice square
blocking the queen and now yeah and so
now doing also playing very thematically
he's trying to solidify his knight in
the in the c4 square wow and magnus
actually goes for the trade immediately
this gives sting a lot of choice dink
can actually recapture this knight in
three ways you can't capture really with
the black knight because there's a pin
the black knight is stuck but you can
catch it with two pawns ivanka
normally we say catcher
towards the center
not away from the center but do you
think black's going to pick up the pawn
in the middle and take this knight just
to open up black's light square bishop
on the diagonal
it's kind of tempting isn't it you know
the bishop has been behind bars for such
a long time so why not free it by
capturing the pawn
with the center capturing the knight
with the santa central pawn yeah big
moment for ding but he's only got four
minutes to think um b porn or d pawn you
have two choices on the menu to take
this white knight
i would use the black d pawn i think
ivanka mentioned she would there too the
black light squared bishop is trapped
behind its own pawns so you have to open
it up i think actually if ding catches
the other way okay he goes for the one
we mentioned if he captured the other
way the black light squared bishop
eternally would have been a bad piece so
at least now he's initiating another
trade of these light squad bishops and
uh okay magnus moves his knight out of
attack and these light squad bishops are
about to leave the board
yeah magnus is playing fast yeah and
once again magnus is in his element he
has the slightly better position you
know he's gonna he has the better pawn
structure he has the pawns that he can
start pushing up the board he's also got
better minor pieces and
ding is totally on the defensive here
and he doesn't have so much time yeah
the evaluation bar might say 0.0 but
this is the type of position that we've
seen countless times from magnus
throughout his career squeezing water
out of a stone and as you mentioned it's
just easier for white to play black's
plans are not obvious at all white's
bishop and knight are better than
black's dark square bishop and knight
and the white queen also is about to
start going towards the black king maybe
it's just easy for white to come up with
plans and with a seven minute time
advantage
i would be i mean if ding holds this one
i'll be full of praise for him uh it
just looks so difficult
just despite what the evaluation bar
says
yeah i'm really not looking at the
evaluation bar is suffering here for
yeah
i mean moves that kind of spring to my
mind is that uh maybe the white knight
can maneuver itself at some point to
attack white's black spawns on the left
side okay so we do see a trade of
bishops and
uh and also doing offering a second
trade yeah interesting maybe he was just
sick of this pin that the uh bishop the
white bishop was having on the black
knight he just brings that black knight
out of the way defending his own bishop
and if we see a trade of the remaining
bishops
still looks pretty good for white i must
admit
magnus is slightly frowning now but uh
at least ding clarifying things slightly
he's hoping maybe with three minutes
left on his clock that trading things
off will make his remaining task a bit
easier um it's hard to play chess with
three minutes when there's so many
pieces on the board especially minor
pieces knights bishops hopping around
everywhere
at least if the remaining bishops
disappear and ding will hope that he can
maybe cover all his weaknesses and hold
the game at least be able to play
quickly with three minutes left
yeah so uh magnus really doesn't have
any choice other than to trade off
bishops
yup trade off bishops and then maybe the
white queen will come into the game and
i'm still uphill here for black to save
the draw yeah
all right
it's um intense and if magnus carlsen
does win this game then it's going to be
he must win forwarding in game four
and uh game four between young
christophe duda and liam lee has started
and that is a must-win situation for
liam lehrer so we're going to pay a
close attention to that game if liam
wins then they will head to target so
far we have not had tie breaks in the
mouthwater champions yesterday 2022
it's getting a little bit likely i would
say um at least if this game is a draw
yeah i think if ding draws this game
tie breaks are very very likely but it's
also a big if whether he'll be able to
hold this one because the evaluation
bars we mentioned maybe not taking into
account the practical um advantages for
white and interesting decision white
actually pushed a pawn in the center of
the board attacking the black knight but
black's queen just sliding across has
pinned the white pawn in the center
because look at the black queen and the
white king they're on the same diagonal
suddenly threats for both sides and
do you think magnus underestimated this
one it looks a bit loose for white
suddenly and uh
maybe there are some tricks still in the
position but yeah there's one big trick
which is like you know you've got to
defend that pawn that's under fire with
your queen that's about that's about the
only thing you can't get also go bishop
takes bishop because of
well maybe you can do bishop takes
bishop
that's what magnus is calculating is it
a big threat that black is planning to
play queen takes the white pawn on the
e4 square with a check
because you can block that maybe with a
pawn but a lot of calculation work to be
done there so magnus most likely is
going to pick up his queen defend his
central pawn and ding will have to reply
to a threat against the black knight
but yeah you want to break pins in
general but dink doing a good job of
trying to at least cause magnus to do a
bit of calculation
and uh magnus now
spending a lot of time in the last
couple of moves he's not got the same
time advantage he previously had and wow
just marching his king up the board
these guys are just fearless wow with
the queens on the board exactly that
would just not be on my radar how do
these top players come up with such
creative moves
it's just amazing defending his central
pawn with his king and also keeping the
white queen on her starting square
because if we see a trade of bishops if
black captures the white bishop and
white recaptures suddenly the white
queen's on an open file
that's why he used the king to defend
not the white queen
i mean wow just wow it looks so bizarre
though to kind of walk into the diagonal
of the black queen and continues the
chaos is just amping up every move
and ivanka you leaned forward after that
one yeah because i am surprised because
uh okay well it allows white to have a
protected passport the best type of
board you know you can go bishop takes
bishop but then there might be an
intermediate move if the white bishop
captures this is really sneaky by black
it's maximum tension right now we
mentioned with this pin with the tension
between these three pawns and also the
tension between these bishops and um if
white plays the move he wants bishop
takes bishop then rather than recapture
with the knight allowing us ivanka
mentioned this beautiful past born
marching up the board then uh i think
black has a sneaky plan in mind what we
call a zvision zig in between move
before capturing this bishop you flick
in a check knight takes pawn check and
when the king moves then you take this
white bishop and actually black wins a
pawn in the process so a sneaky sneaky
idea there from ding and magnus he tries
to block this pin against his king with
his knight
and maximum tension look at all these
pieces in the center of the board
kyle you mentioned taking center that's
one of the key concepts but this is in
the end game they're still fighting
still fighting hard for the center of
the board all of these pieces under fire
there's a lot of pressure on black's
bishop here and remember if you trade
off the bishops in the wrong way then
suddenly the white queen might become
active on this open file then again at
least black can plug this open file with
his own knight and with a check
so both knights now on beautiful
outposts it's not clear whose knight is
better to be honest and yeah the current
position super tense i'm expecting this
black bishop to move just what else and
uh
yeah the chaos will continue definitely
lots of chaos on the board because i'm
just running through the possibilities
where you're talking you know you have
bishop takes bishop very good i like
that one
there's also pawn takes porn as well
yeah panties pawn looks very tempting
okay so okay we have actually seen
bishop takes
we have seen the bishops leave the board
under the line that you mentioned
the night coming in so the big question
now is this pawn that white has that's
unsupported a little bit alone
is it a target yeah the problem is how
to attack this board you've got to be
really careful if you bring your queen
next to the bond to attack it whoops you
walk into a night fork you've got to be
so careful here this is a check
attacking the queen and uh it's not easy
to actually target what looks like a
really weak unsupported pawn and maybe
you can bring your queen to the edge of
the board sometimes to attack it from
this angle maybe you can start bringing
your king closer to the center just to
avoid any potential checks
either way
i mean it's looking really symmetrical
with these knights but whose pawn is
stronger this past pawn which might be a
weakness or black's protected pawn here
which isn't a passport
but uh looks quite strong and okay he
does bring his king closer to the middle
of the board i like that one just
stopping any checks and now the threat
of picking up this white pawn at your
leisure
okay let's go back to the players this
one
still very tense despite the fact we are
in an end game queens are on the board
but queen and night and games they are
super tricky and uh one minute and 37
seconds left for ding how is he in these
when you know when there's not much time
left basically yeah we we saw him be
actually very
impressive he he was very calm and he
played some good moves you know he
didn't have so much time against uh
magnus in
in game i've forgotten the game when
magnus had the white pieces so game one
game say game one and uh we saw him find
some great defensive resources with just
over a minute on the clock so i've been
very impressed by ding and also i still
remember that night end game that he
played with seconds on his clock against
jordan van forest so he is good
but you know it isn't an easy task and
mistakes can be made
yeah i would say magnus is maybe the
more experienced of the two when they're
both under 30 seconds one minute uh
magnus may be slightly trickier than
ding is but uh yeah i think he's number
three in the world for a reason he's
been top five in the world for most of
the last what five six years so yeah
he's
he's definitely one of the sharpest
players out there but he's done a good
job so far it's still going to be tricky
i'm not sure who's even playing for the
win here ah i think magnus would love to
just activate the white queen and start
creating some threats but if she goes
off to the right side of the board and
attacking some pawns those pawns are
simply defended
okay he tries to open things up explode
open the center he's trying to undermine
the defender of the black knight so the
pawn that has just been pushed by white
cannot be captured because black would
lose his knight in the center so that
one
it looks very aggressive but the
downside is white's king now
also equally open
yeah every move pros and cons this one
it was on my radar i was hesitant to
suggest it just because it looks
too brave if anything yeah i was a
little bit hesitant to suggest it as
well because i thought well in effect
what's going to happen is that black is
just going to target
to the c5 pawn it's original target and
there you go and all white can do is
maybe capture the pawn and then
who who does this benefit i thought
benefited black yeah black's king
it's heading towards the center but it
is pretty safe
no checks around but you could imagine a
situation where white's knight
disappears and the white king becomes
really uh vulnerable so okay magnus's
idea his hidden idea was to bring his
queen out to the side of the board and
hit black's pawn in the center now but
look at the evaluation bar it's changing
it's swinging and i guess the queen
i don't know maybe it just can't break
through towards the center if ding is
accurate maybe ding
wow i was about to say
maybe ding can copy what magnus was
trying to do look at the tension with
the pawns in on the fourth and fifth
ranks there's so many pawns there and uh
this one undermines the defender of the
white knight so this pawn that's just
pushed cannot be captured because
white's knight in the center would fall
and magnus
slightly shook his head there he's
trying to keep a poker face but i think
he missed this move ooh well and ding he
is though in uh huge time trouble 56
seconds left on the clock and uh if you
want to make a bid for the gaming uh
successful gaming and chess cherry
you're also in time trouble eight
minutes left
to make your bed
all right wow some quick moves we saw
actually a trade of pawns in the center
and white's just stepped this pawn up
white is threatening checkmate in one
move white's queen wants to slide up on
the diagonal in front of the black king
and deliver checkmate this pawn was just
too strong supporting that checkmating
idea so ding has eliminated it so ding
is one pawn up
but there's a threat against the black
queen and actually white's pieces are
starting to combine towards the black
king maybe
neither king safe here can ding
capitalize on his extra pawn
woof black queen needs to choose a safe
square though that's not an easy task i
mean the most natural move is actually
just to slide the queen one one square
to the right just checking that into f6
um just to kind of be in close
connection
to the king
and i don't think it's under
any form of attack because if the knight
moves then the queen can well try and
trade itself off yeah i agreed you could
maybe even offer a queen trade right now
uh there's a couple of squares from
which you can do that but look at ding's
clock 13 seconds 12 seconds 10 i mean
he's got a huge decision he's got five
or six squares but only maybe two of
them are safe he offers a queen trade or
yeah he now he has to deal with a huge
threat against the black knight the
black knight undefended
if you defend this night with your queen
the white queen will take this night
anyway and there's a nasty night check
nasty night forks coming four seconds
three seconds he has to move he's gonna
move his knife and he's gone for a
counter attack wow okay now it feels
like magnus has got a chance
queen takes knight as possible here the
white knight might fall but white is the
first to give some checks to the black
king
and white has this really scary c pawn
only three squares away from promotion
right and it's the quality of the pawns
not the quantity three
is uh
take the knight
uh maybe he could
make an argument for trading a set of
pawns first
i don't think the white knight can move
not many options for white okay he does
trade a set of pawns first and there we
go the knights have disappeared okay and
it's running
with all those things squares away from
promotion and as ivanka mentioned it's
not the number of pawns you have it's
about how advanced they are and white is
two squares away from promotion black is
losing the race black's pawns still take
a while to push forward ding has to go
for perpetual check here he has to find
a way to check the white king eternally
with his queen but to do that less than
10 seconds again
there's a narrow path to a draw here but
i'm not sure i would find it even with
30 minutes on my clock he's got 10
seconds okay and
this is a great move it's uh capturing a
pawn but also liberating the queen so if
the white queen gets a bit too far away
from her king then black's queen can
start checking so excellent defense from
ding wow okay white pushed upon that it
looks like he was about to promote but
ding took a time out to just move his
king
such calmness the black queen actually
covers the promotion square of that
white pawn the c8 square
and there's no checks for white there's
no checks at white's disposal how is he
going to make that pawn push forward if
he moves the white queen then black's
queen will come and give some checks
maybe now is the time just to
go brave with the king take the pawn and
run
take the pawn in front of the white king
yeah possibly
i think black can actually give some
checks there though and maybe win the
white sea pawn
and black would be out of trouble so oh
magnus i don't think there's a way
forward for him i think ding has found
the only way to save the draw
imagine that he had two seconds on his
clock a few moves ago he's finding the
best moves that's how good he is that's
why everyone wants to see him in the
candidates tournament because he can
fight toe to toe with magnus he i mean
he's surviving these really treacherous
positions
okay what is their left magnus the
problem is the black queen is coming to
deliver some checks okay there's no
check for
okay
huge threat on the board now yeah white
is now threatening to push the pawn that
would be a discovered check look on the
seventh rank the white queen and king
and the black king lined up so black
either has to move his king which looks
really scary or you have to give a check
six seconds
six seconds well maybe he can start
checking now and he moves his king and
okay and the computer has uh oh look at
that
magnus he's retreated his queen okay he
stopped any checks
this is so clever and now i was thought
the position was about to repeat itself
but white's queen's actually on a better
square than she previously was
can she just go and capture the pawn now
in front of the white king yes you can
yeah white is suddenly winning i was
just praising ding but magnus found a
trick ding just panicked with no time on
his clock he lost two moves and now
there's no checks white's pawn is going
to decide this game and white has a huge
threat on the board he's going to step
back on the diagonal with the queen and
offer a trade of queens and the king
cannot catch the pawn so the queen had
to run away from any potential trades
but now magnus if he's super clever i
think he might be able to can you not
just move the queen one step to the
right yeah you're right you're
completely correct there ding realizing
white has a winning move just slides the
queen across he's done it yeah
supporting that white pawn indirectly
black can no longer hold the fortress
white porn is about to make another
queen
and make that move with one second but
this is just one check
the king is hiding away but uh that's it
a second queen is going to come and ding
has resigned magnus has won wow
what a game huge time trouble for dingle
in the middle of the night in china and
he wasn't able to find the